olá pessoal de quem fala é o dar que
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e
os estragos já que em novo especial big
mac menu de uru está muito bom talvez
nós vamos fazer aqui uma coisa que nunca
fiz eu tenho a ver umas coisas na
internet e eu encontrei um site muito
gostoso o tema vida que várias comidas
que as pessoas ricas comem por aquelas
pessoas que podem ostentar tem dinheiro
muito dinheiro mesmo vai só que elas
comem ao big mac de ouro tablet é duro
mas são de ouro do núcleo duro exame eo
meu muita coisa de ouro eu nunca fui uma
pessoa rica mas sempre quis comer uma
dessas comidas de ouro é por isso hoje
vamos tentar aqui fazer uma seita do big
mac de ouro mil big mac é aquela comida
que toda a gente gosta nem quem é que
nunca comi um big mac no começo e para
fazer esta receita do nosso big mac ou
nós precisamos apenas duas coisas duas
top do nosso menu big mac e integrada
muita tinta dourada muita tinta na qual
era o único escolas pro outro no mercado
russo e espero que vamos abrir o nosso
meio óbvio já começar pela batata que é
sempre melhor né
a coca cola também e agora o mais
importante é o nosso big mac menu é
gostoso e aí é pra [ __ ] por um saco
pessoal nosso big mac banho gostosinho
alguém bonito brasileiro nessa e até vou
brincar aqui eu só tenho que depois eu
só tento ok só para testarmos de tinta a
primeira coisa que vou fazer é pintar
uma batata e ver o que acontece e já
está bem frio
vamos lá ver esta quinta falcioni
ok chega ao colégio e não tem muita
diferença ela continua amarela mas já
sabia que uma tinta que não eu acho que
se for mais né
[Música]
a tupy pintar tudo
acho muito fundão mas está durando
estado e vejam que já estava em dourados
bem que não se nota muito porque a
batata já amarela em cinema mas eu acho
que vai funcionar para o hamburgo e eu
acho que sim
o time está a apenas luvas primeiro
canalha é difícil pôr o dedo aqui em
primeira quanto a funciona a vaca assim
o álbum solo e em lei lei que pretende
ficar completamente o menu todo de ouro
eu vou pintar e comida e também
embalagem eu vou pintar a coca cola ou
pintar esta caixinha e vou pintar também
é caixa da batata e para não desperdiçar
a coca-cola eu vou como o cara que a
coca cola num cofre não dois olhos mas
esses quatro copos né photoshop com 14
15 16 horas que você chega né lei 4
chega quando chegou agora sim pessoal
que atende uma laje brasil já podemos
pintar sem esfregar a coca-cola nem que
qualquer folga quer corre corre que ela
espera que com isso e não o povo é e
tentava deixar o povo feliz agora vamos
pintar aqui embalagem da copa guga jogou
só tá boi dourado está mesmo muito bom
este é o começo da ostentação mesmo aí
brutal
ok pessoal é que temos a nossa primeira
embalagem de ouro já pintava coca-cola
todo o meu tá muito a ostentação mesmo
vejam só tá muito a sustentação
só falta aqui uma coisa é paulinha e
diana que está aqui pra voltar pra linha
pessoal estão mais capazes também vai
segurar a não esperando para eu não vou
enfiar a polícia porque eu vou pintar
está partido
agora sim ta prefeito já temos de bebida
é paulinha e agora só falta a batata eo
big mac
agora vamos pintar porque não posso
pintar e comer portanto não vou estragar
a comida não fica muito bem esta idéia
de movimento então papel vou usar aqui
esta tinta tóxica e depois eu vou usar
outra quinta combustível preta batata e
só depois desse cara e comentou olha só
o ouro da batata anahí meus e comida do
guru da eurocopa posição outro copo a
isso não vai comentar aqui a nossa
embalagem de batata do metrô não está
completamente de ouro já tá aqui nossa
batata ostentação só pintar aqui os
últimos toques a pinto eo braço adentrem
braços abertos ao g5 tal a fuga sem ter
minha pulseira nova mas um lixo
agora vamos pintar o nosso hambúrguer
nosso big mac olha só olha só o nosso
grande pigmeu época e agora vou tentar
tirar da caixa sem fazer um boné
muito cuidado daqui nós hambúrguer
pessoal e agora vamos pintar caixola e
produção murilo lução roupa
o árbitro muito bem ganhou 56 disponível
produção começo a gente foi lá o pior
mesmo tempo cheia é bom intenso mas o
tempo está ficando bonito mesmo virar ao
contrário adora viajar ea pessoal está a
ficar muito rápido assim eu vou agora só
mirar as peças o contrário estar outro
lado a não olha só mesa tanta pintada
homicídio já o pessoal vamos lá então
pintar as nossas batatas
acho que isso é que é informada não
saiba se destacou a cni isso é
inflamável em álcool vão estar ligando
ok só as nossas batatas já estão
pintadas agora eu vou decepcioná-los
todas voltaram por dentro do copo
esperar que elas téchiné
agora vamos pintar nossa música trazem
produção seja a opção da campanha faça
em casa tem todo o big mac tem e agora
vamos pintar tudo com um spray dourado
low o pessoal aqui produção olha aqui
aí eu brotou tá muito bonito
vejam só pessoal contar o nosso big mac
e ostentação camista durado só para que
o stoxx ataque um pouquinho e sim a avó
lançou edu inícia exato é que a
embalagem diz que não sabia nada e que é
combustível e não só mesmo nada de mim
eu vou repetir alguém não saiba nada não
sabia nada juro botafogo
o cheiro é essa mesmo agora é só pra te
come de que as embalagens técnica e
depois dos jogos mostra o sofá à final e
vamos também testar o nosso orgulho em
ver se ainda continua segurança observa
que só tenho que tudo tentava agora é só
começar por as coisas dentro de
embalagens e vamos lá para a exposição
coca cola produção um copo de coca cola
mas um copo ou três copos da coca-cola
ok pessoal um copo de coca cola é que
está a nossa coca cola completa de ouro
ainda não está completa porque falta uma
coisa essencial meu olha só como ficou o
da brutal meu eu vejo um só batata
dourada está muito bonito eu já tenho a
coca cola já temos a batata e agora
falta o nosso big mac
vejam só como eu tá bonito pessoal nosso
big mac ouro vejam aqui dentro
aqui dentro é completamente normal ou
che meu cão lendo temos aqui o
hambúrguer e batatas fritas e coca cola
agora vão experimentar os três vamos lá
o técnico então saiba coca cola a
idêntico está muito bom
lucia batata frita mas não só pessoal é
batata está dourada 321 tóxica já saí
por incrível que pareça sobem
a batata só votariam
isso não tem sabor juro é bom os lábios
mil tomar prova prova está muito bom e
aí eu vou está muito boa assim não tem
subúrbio é nossa 'batata' é provada um
tá muito bom tá muito tanto os tribunais
estão durando meu blog só novo batom
dourada que é batata extensão da batata
aprovada muito bom mesmo e agora vamos
testar o nosso hambúrguer de ouro 32 o
sabor diferente
então eu é muito bom humor ao qual não é
que o álcool da bebida é calc com eu não
sei que o cara é bom ter desistido que o
início que por 100.000 dó sol fizeram um
big mac ouro 100 mil dólares é só aqui
que eu faço para ir por dentro até vou
pintar aqui mais hall num chute cheio de
ouro muito bom comentou embaixo mas como
em dois períodos mar em outro tipo sei
lá pisa oréal qualquer coisa nova meta
pessoal se nós conseguirmos chegar aos
100 mil likes neste livro eu vou fazer
uma pizza gigante de ouro pizza gigante
de ouros e milagres como embaixo do sol
santos de ouro e aqui no lado você está
em dois vídeos poderão vir aqui em cima
mas também podem subscrever aqui no
canal da frente é isso está muito bom e
até a próxima